[Music]
Berlin is my home hide man
the Moabite district of berlin was once
a working-class neighborhood Danny Hawk
opened angora want here in 2006
back then it was Germany's first
Cambodian restaurant it's just a stone's
throw from Bellevue Palace the official
residence of the German President Danny
Hawk gets many of his ingredients in
Asian food stores or at the wholesaler
the more exotic ingredients can't be
found in many grocery stores I like
coming here it's now my restaurant so
it's a quick trick and I can get
everything I need in my kitchen
these lime leaves have an intense flavor
we use them for seasoning I love them
Danny Hawk came to Germany in 1988 when
he was just 19 in Cambodia he grew up
with foster parents and an uncle after
losing his entire family to the brutal
Khmer Rouge regime he still has contact
with his foster father and others back
home three years ago
Danny and some friends paid a visit to
the place in Cambodia where as a nine
year old boy he had buried his own
mother the mayor of the local community
also helped him find his mother's grave
and Danny held a Buddhist ceremony in
her memory
[Music]
although he still feels a strong tie to
Cambodia today Danny calls Berlin home
under clan when I think of home I
remember my parents in Cambodia when I
was little I miss it a lot I also missed
the food my mother used to cook for me I
wasn't allowed to help just watch I
remember the food in the sense those
familiar sense always remind me of home
cook for the athan women here in one
region than Malik support and a hide man
amok tray is a traditional Cambodian
dish amok comes in many different
versions it can be made with fish
usually monkfish Pangasius or sea bass
or with chicken or tofu
[Music]
Cambodian food is flavorful but not as
spicy hot as many other Southeast Asian
cuisines is a Cambodian term for cooking
curry in banana leaves trade means with
fish steaming helps the dish develop its
flavors amok tray is served in a bowl on
a bed of banana leaves and rice in
Cambodia - under in Cambodia we used
different vegetables one is similar to
spinach for example but not the kind
that we know here in Germany people here
don't like it much that's why we also
use other ingredients like pineapple the
bell peppers and mushrooms but the basic
flavor of our mock-up is the same as
you'd get in Cambodia in Cambodia shared
meals are an important part of the
culture it's a tradition that Danny Hawk
wants to pass on he sees his role not
just as chef but is host to its cosy he
and I like that the place just has a
very nice feel to it the waiters are
very friendly and happy to recommend
nice dishes it's very homey here this is
I'm finally here whenever I long for our
food back home I come here and speak
Cambodian with the owner and listen to
my music playing in the background then
I feel like I'm back home they've
adapted some of the dishes to European
tastes but it's always delicious you can
eat a lot without getting fat too
the Cambodian community in Berlin is
still fairly small but many come here to
Angkor Wat
- enjoy the familiar foods and flavors
[Music]
predicament - I hope I'm afraid I've
never our Kalia someone doing tonight